クリロフ量子対角化、略してKQDとは、行列の固有値問題を
量子コンピュータ上で準備した部分空間に行列を射影することで解く手法で、古典的な線形代数の
強力なアプローチであるクリロフ法と一致している。このビデオを通じて、クリロフ法が何に役立つのか、
そして量子コンピュータ上でいつ・どのように実装するかを探っていく。
クリロフ法とは何か？n行n列の
行列Hが科学的・ビジネス的な課題に関連しているとしよう。最小固有値e0と対応する固有ベクトルψ0に興味がある。初期
ベクトルvを定義しよう。これはhの構造から動機付けられることもあれば、完全にランダムな場合もある。次数rのクリロフ部分空間、
k rと書くものは、この初期ベクトルにhを
r-1回作用させ、各hの作用の結果を
張るベクトルの集合に加えることで生成される。つまりkrはベクトルv、
hv、h²vなどで張られる空間だ。これらのベクトルは一般に直交しない。
古典的には、グラム・シュミット法によく似た直交化処理を行うことが多い。まず
初期ベクトルVを正規化してV0と呼ぶ。次のベクトルHVについては、その
V0への射影を引いて2つのベクトルを直交させる。そして結果を正規化する。これを繰り返し、
再びHを作用させて、結果を以前に追加したすべてのベクトルと直交させていき、R次元クリロフ部分空間を張るのに必要な
R個の正規直交ベクトルを構築するまで続ける。
この部分空間が得られたら、行列をその上に射影し、より小さな射影行列を対角化する。
細かい点や拡張はあるが、それが最も単純なレベルでのクリロフ法だ。
どのように動作するか感覚をつかむため、単純な例を見てみよう。HがこのようなあるいはVがこのような
ベクトルとして選ばれた場合、まずVを正規化することから始める。クリロフ部分空間の2番目のベクトルを生成するには、初期ベクトルにHを1度
作用させ、その結果をV0に直交させる。
少し計算するとV1はこうなる。
このような小さな行列には意味がなく、通常はkryof次元2で止まることもない。しかし
新しいkryof空間K2にHを射影するとしたら、行列V、つまり
各列にkryofベクトルを持つ行列と、各行にkryofベクトルを持つ転置共役行列を使ってこれを行う。そして
この行列が得られる。
この行列は技術的には元の行列より次元が低い。明らかに、このスケールでは次元削減は意味をなさない。
この手法は、何千、何百万もの行と列を持つ行列を
わずかな数まで削減するためのものだ。では、なぜクリロフ法が役立つのか？この単純な演算子作用の処方が
行列演算子の最小固有値状態、つまり基底状態に近づくための最も効率的な方法であることが多いことがわかっている。
もう少し明確にしよう、完全な証明は付随するテキストに譲る。hがベクトルxに作用するとある定数とベクトルxの積になるという
形の問題を解きたい。まず固有ベクトルの推測x0から始める。これはただの近似解だ。e0と呼ぶ誤差がある。次に
この推測の更新x1を行いたい。これにより近似が改善されることを期待する。これを
元のx0に未定の補正p0を加えたものとして表せる。
このプロセスを反復的に繰り返し、補正ベクトルpiをどんどん追加できる。
当然、誤差を減らしたいが、気にするのは状態だけではない。その状態に対するhの
作用も重要だ。だから本当に最小化したい量は、この誤差のhノルム、つまり
この誤差へのhの作用のノルムだ。
これはp0を含む表式であり、誤差のhノルムを最も効率的に最小化するpの選択が
何かを問うことができる。どの空間から補正を選ぶべきか？hが対称かつ正定値である場合などの
特定の条件下では、krから最初のr個の補正を選ぶことが
最適であることがわかっている。より簡単に言えば、ハミルトニアンを射影できる良い部分空間を準備する方法が必要で、
多くの場合、クリロフ部分空間は初期推測への最も
効率的な補正ベクトルで張られる空間だ。
実際の証明については、このビデオに付随するテキストを参照してほしい。
これまで説明してきたことはすべて古典的に実行できる。では、量子コンピュータをどのように、いつ使うのか？
非常に大きな行列の場合、クリロフ法は長い計算時間と大量のメモリを必要とすることがある。
HをVに行列演算する際に必要な時間は最悪の場合N²のオーダーでスケールする。
そしてこれは部分空間に求めるすべてのベクトルに対して行われる。部分空間次元Rは通常Nの有意な
割合ではなく、多くの場合Nのlogのようなオーダーでスケールするためすべてのベクトルの生成は
N²logNのオーダーでスケールする。
直交化などの他のステップもあるが、これが念頭に置くべき支配的なスケーリングだ。
量子コンピューティングにより、問題のどの属性が時間とリソースのスケーリングを決定するかを変えることができる。
行列サイズnへの全面的な依存の代わりに、ショット数や
ハミルトニアンを構成する非可換パウリ項の数のようなものが出てくる。
どのように動作するか探ってみよう。
量子状態を時間発展させる演算子はiHをh-barで割った指数関数であることを思い出してほしい。そして
特に量子コンピューティングでは、表記からh-barを省くことが非常に一般的だ。
演算子のこのような指数関数を理解し実現する一つの方法は、そのフーリエ
級数展開を見ることだ。この演算が初期ベクトルVに作用すると、項の和が得られることに注意してほしい。
初期状態にHを累乗して適用していく形だ。Krylov部分空間は時間
初期推定状態を時間発展させることで生成できそうだ。これはほぼ正しい。ただし注意点がある——
実際の量子コンピュータ上で時間発展を実現するにあたってだ。ハミルトニアンの多くの項は互いに
可換でない。だからe^のような単純な指数演算子はシンプルな
circuitに対応するが、一般的なハミルトニアンはそうでなく、非可換項を含むため
数値の場合のように指数を単純な積に分解できない。これは
自明ではないが、量子コンピューティングでよく研究されているプロセスだ。時間発展は
トロッター化と呼ばれるプロセスを使って量子コンピュータ上で実行される——これ自体が豊かなテーマだ。だが非常に高いレベルで言えば、
時間発展をM個のような小さなステップに分割することで、項の非可換性の影響を
制限できる。古典的な文脈でhのべき乗を使って生成した次数rのKrylov部分空間を
power Krylov部分空間kprと呼ぼう。
次に、ihtの指数で与えられるユニタリ時間発展演算子uを使って同様の空間を生成する。
これをunitary Krylov空間kurと呼ぶ。
古典的に使うpower Krylov部分空間kprは、hがユニタリ演算子でないため量子コンピュータ上で直接生成できない。
unitary Krylov部分空間を使うことで、power Krylov部分空間と同様の収束
保証が得られることを示せる。
具体的には、初期状態Vが真の基底状態と指数関数的に消えない
重なりを持ち、固有
状態間に十分なギャップがある限り、基底状態誤差は効率的に収束する。ここでuのべき乗は異なる時間ステップになる。uのk乗は
時間k * dtだけ前進することだ。
合計時間kdtだけ時間発展した部分空間の要素をs_kと表記できる。
ハミルトニアンHをunitary Krylov部分空間kurに射影できる。つまり、
kurの基底でhの各行列要素を計算する。これを
射影行列H~と呼ぼう。H~の行列要素は量子コンピュータで
推定できるこれらの期待値で与えられる。
Hは異なるqubit上のパウリ演算子の和として書けること、そしてすべてのパウリ演算子が
同時に測定できるわけではないことを念頭に置いてほしい。可換な項のグループにパウリ項を分類し、
そのすべてを一度に測定できる。だが全項をカバーするには多くのグループが必要になる場合がある。だから項を分割できる可換グループの数
ngcpが重要になる。次元rのunitary Krylov部分空間を使う場合、
結果の行列はr × rの次元になる。rがnよりずっと小さければ
有益な進展だ。通常rは100をはるかに下回るので、古典コンピュータで簡単に対角化できる。
ただし、s_nとs_mは一般に直交しないことを思い出してほしい。
非直交基底で行列を対角化できる場合もある。しかし数値的・物理的な理由から
まず直交基底に変換する方がよい。したがってグラム行列sを使って一般化固有値問題を解く。
グラム行列のmn要素はs_mとs_nの内積で与えられる。
H~とSの要素はどちらもHadamardテストを使って計算される。
一般化固有値問題はこうなる。
前述の通り、unitary Krylov部分空間の次元Rは初期
行列次元Nより指数関数的に小さい。だからこの固有値問題は古典的に簡単に解ける。
まとめると、参照状態から始め、それをさまざまな時間だけ発展させてunitary
Krylov部分空間を生成する。ハミルトニアンをその部分空間に射影し、部分空間ベクトルの
重なりも推定する。最後に低次元の一般化固有値問題を古典的に解く。Krylov手法を古典的・量子力学的に使う場合の
計算コストを決める要因を比較してみよう。古典バージョンについてはすでに概説したが、
古典と量子のアプローチの間にすべてのステップで完全な類比があるわけではない。だがこの表は考察のためにいくつかのステップのスケーリングをまとめている。
ハミルトニアンには一般に同時測定できない項があることを思い出してほしい——可換でないからだ。
ハミルトニアンの項を同時測定できる可換パウリ演算子のグループに分類するが、非可換な全項を考慮するために多くの
グループが必要になる場合がある。量子コンピュータ上でH~を構築するには
ハミルトニアン内の可換パウリ文字列の各グループに対して個別の測定が必要だ。そしてそれぞれに多くのショットが必要だ。これをR
乗した異なる時間発展因子の組み合わせに対応するR^2個の異なる行列要素に対して行わなければならない。
これを削減する方法もある場合がある。しかしこの大まかな扱いでは、これに必要な時間はおよそ
ショット数 × 可換パウリ項のグループ数 × r^2のようにスケールする。
Sの要素も推定が必要で、ショット数の
3乗のようにスケールする。ハミルトニアン内の可換パウリグループの数が比較的少ない場合に量子Krylov対角化が有用になることがわかる。
ハミルトニアン内の可換グループが比較的少ない場合だ。
このスケーリングの依存性は、Krylov法が有用な応用とそうでない応用を示唆している。
ハミルトニアンの中には、qubitへのマッピング時に多くの非可換パウリ文字列を含む高複雑度なものがある——
少数の可換グループに容易に分割できないものだ。
これは量子化学問題でよく当てはまる。例えばこの複雑さはニアタームの
量子コンピュータに対して2つの主な課題をもたらす。第一に、H~の各要素の推定が
項の多さにより計算コストが高くなる。第二に、必要なトロッター化circuitが非現実的に深くなる。これら2点は
量子コンピュータがフォールトトレランスに達すれば問題が少なくなるが、ニアタームでは考慮が必要だ。より単純なマッピングを持つシステムでも
量子化学のものよりも、ハミルトニアンに非可換な項が多すぎる場合、同様の障害に直面する可能性がある。
Krylov法は、ハミルトニアンが比較的少数の可換な多項式の
グループに分割でき、HがTrotterのcircuitで実装しやすい場合に最も有用だ。これらの条件は両方とも満たされている。例えば、
物理学で注目されている多くの格子モデルに対して。KQDは基底状態についてほとんど何もわかっていない場合に特に有用だ。
これは、その固有の収束保証と、基底状態の知識が不十分なために
代替手法が使えない場面での適用可能性から来ている。
KQDは強力なツールだが、このプロトコルの時間のかかる側面、特に各
射影されたハミルトニアンの要素とKrylov状態の重なりの推定は、改善の余地を示している。
別のアプローチとして、Trotterのcircuitを使ってKrylov状態を近似し、その
近似された状態をサンプリングして計算基底への射影を得て、その部分空間にhを射影する方法がある。
これらの計算基底状態によって張られる。
適用可能な場合、この手法はサンプリングベースKrylov量子対角化SKQDとして知られ、
従来のKQDと比較して、時間とリソース要件の大幅な削減をもたらす可能性がある。
SKQDにおけるKrylov部分空間技術とサンプリング手法の統合は、量子アルゴリズムにおける
エキサイティングなフロンティアを表している。